I saw this documentary on uh I think it
was Hulu Ashley Madison documentary
bro you guys know about Ashley Madison I
didn't know about I I didn't know about
astronauts I did not know about this
series on Hulu that they have
um
and it's still up the website Ashley
Madison Ashley Madison is a website that
promotes extramarital affairs
wow dude you can download the app on
Apple
I'm shocked you can get the iPhone app
this is crazy bro that this website
exists millions of people just like you
are looking for a discreet connection so
everyday people like you okay so so
here's the deal
I mean this is crazy look at the website
when monogamy becomes monotony this is
so crazy actually I've never seen this
website this is crazy to actually look
at this
did you know infidelity is emotional
while adultery is physical cheating is a
nuanced topic and everyone has different
reasons for joining a dating site like
Ashley Madison our members are united in
a desire to seek out wow
that is just wild and then this so this
so in 2002
look at this the the quote I cheated on
my member experiences I cheated on my
husband to find companionship and to
feel happy and alive again I I love how
they don't quote the dudes you know
I was looking for [__] Craig
Idaho
didn't get it by the way
couldn't find really anybody or most of
the women were fat or fake dude
so in 2002 it started they got like you
know a few maybe a hundred thousand
uh
people on it which is a lot but then by
like 2007 they were saying that they had
like 60 million or something anyway the
dude who was CR the Creator not the
Creator the CEO I forget his name
something like Ned meterlander went on a
bunch of talk shows and was like yo this
is what it is and everyone hated him it
was the most hated guy in the world
whatever
and so someone hacked his [__] and
exposed everything on Ashley Madison
and expose everybody they expose
everybody on Ashley Madison and saying
how like uh
they gave him a month to defunct the
website and the Ned needle and the guy
was like no I'm not doing that [__] so
they exposed everybody
people started killing themselves
because they were exposed they were
losing jobs the fact that they were not
cheating
um and our whole time watching this [__]
and I'm just like man thank God I was
never on Ashley Madison dude
crazy bro
so crazy so now it's still it's still uh
they they got sued because they were
making fake profiles of women because
dude when you make a website like this
there's one kind of person that are on
that's on this these websites
dudes
and I know women cheat too but not like
this dude
women don't cheat women don't go looking
to cheat you know what I mean women go
like this wait a minute I I I'm in way
over my head I I shouldn't be doing this
they're fixing their [__]
I think it's out of control they'll say
it's out of control before anything even
happened
we really shouldn't be I know but and I
by mistake I I think that we held each
other's gaze too long
I know we were at separate restaurants
across the street
but we were looking through the window
and I got way ahead of myself I I I I
have a they're not even with someone
already I've had I'm gonna have a family
one day with somebody if I meet them
and do dudes go to the [__]
so they they were like and then and then
they made fake profiles for women
because they needed more women they were
something like something like 65 60
million this is not but it was something
like
45 million people on it and like 44.5
million people on it were men okay so
it's like all right if 500 000 women are
on it which is by the way a lot of women
a lot of women how many of them are hot
how many
now let me be let me be generous
let me err on the side of the positive
four
you're probably if you're smart you're
probably like Prime item four
hot
women who go to a website to cheat
I mean honestly men who go to a website
to cheat
ugly pretty safe bet right no job right
so then what do you call it they got
exposed for the fake profiles and fraud
and then it's like they got sued but not
really because they're still in business
they didn't
[__] the company up all that much
now they boast 65 million members online
which I don't know how true that is but
dude hey
no [__] you're talking to someone fake
on the internet dude I don't I don't
know if you the internet's the kind of
thing when
it's the kind of thing when you like
it's the same idea as when you like
found out Kevin Spacey was gay you know
when you if you're talking to someone
fake on the Internet it's the same thing
as it's like someone says oh you're
talking to someone fake on you you're
that person's fake you go uh yeah maybe
oh yeah yeah
right like he's not out there just like
I put a sign up right in the front
window advertisement right in the front
window and all of a sudden success
coming out of the blue right he's in
dope [__] like seven you know what I'm
saying
but now when someone says yo he's gay
kind of you go yeah oh yeah
now that's on you
to not know that [__] the guys want it
to be real so bad you know I was at a
strip club once a long long time ago I'm
talking about 20 years with a buddy and
this uh stripper was like I want to hang
out with you tonight with me with a
buddy and he was like oh okay and he was
like wait for me outside and he said
okay and we're waiting outside and I was
like bro she's not coming out man she's
not she's like I know I know I'll never
forget it because he was like I know
dude that I trust me dude I know when
someone's lying and she's not lying and
she never came out of course and we
waited for way too long and [__]
drove home afterwards because dude you
got had man
you got had
so anyway there's 65 million people that
they say is on Ashley Madison
incredible but now they can't get their
security was so bad it was so easy to
hack apparently in the documentary the
documentary was pretty [__] good I
had to stop watching it
uh because it triggered me so [__]
hard now it's got to be foolproof right
there's no way that they'll get hacked
crazy crazy crazy
[Music]